- I kind of weirdly want
people to pull over right now.
I realize if you get letters
or calls that people got
into accidents,
that's on you guys.
I'm waiving all my liability.
- Thank you, Gary.
- I want you to pull over.
I want you look at that mirror,
rearview mirror, right,
that's what it's called, right?
- [Woman] Yeah, yeah.
- Thank you.
I want you to look at it, you
need to understand if you
look at it, it's your fault.
- [Elvis] What do you mean?
- Everything in life is on you.
- [Elvis] Right.
- It's not your dad's
fault who was a drinker.
It's not your boyfriend
that, you know, cheated on you.
It's not your girlfriend
who's always putting you down.
It is your fundamental fault.
The second you
make that decision
then you can go on the offense.
(hip hop music)